DOMINIC PREUSS: Good morning,
everyone, or good afternoon.
It's been a long day already.
My name is Dominic
Preuss I'm the product
lead for storage and databases
on the Google Cloud platform.
Very excited to speak
to you guys today
about how to you scale
your ideas from concepts
to petabyte.
The goal of this talk
is really to give you
an overview of our storage
offerings and our databases,
and to give you a set of
reference architectures
that you can use when
you're considering
how to build your applications.
These are not prescriptive.
These are just some
things to give you
an idea of how people are
structuring these things so
that when you are
getting ready to bring
your applications
to Google Cloud,
you've got a starting point.
I want to start by talking
about the Google data platform.
So when we talk about
the data platform,
we really think of it
in a very holistic way.
We don't think about individual
products or silos of data.
The idea here is that we have an
integrated, no ops, cloud data
platform that allows you
to build your applications.
And most importantly, it's
about you bringing your data
to the Google Cloud
platform in the way that
makes sense for you.
And then us making
sure that we offer
you tools that allow you to
move, transform, and derive
value from your data, regardless
of where it is the platform.
A very good example
of this is making
sure-- we've talked a lot
about machine learning--
where are you going to
store your training data?
And all of that information
has to be in the platform
somewhere.
And so how do you
go about doing that?
So as a level set, let's talk
about the portfolio of storage
offerings and databases.
First of all, the one that
most people know about
is Google Cloud Storage.
So this is our object
storage system.
It's designed for both
structured and unstructured
data.
And people use it, obviously,
for serving static content
like images and
video, but it's also
used for archival, backups,
and as an intermediate data
location for data
processing jobs.
Once we get into the
databases, our oldest offering,
original offering, or one
of our earliest offerings,
is Cloud SQL.
So if you need a managed MySQL
solution-- again, no ops,
you spin up an
instance and you have
a database-- Cloud SQL
is the solution for you.
This is really useful
if you're using
a web framework or some
existing application that
requires MySQL, or some
other off the shelf RDBMS.
And by RDBMS, I mean Relational
Database Management System.
If you want a NoSQL solution
and want to go down that path,
we offer two solutions.
One is Cloud Datastore.
Cloud Datastore really
serves the document store use
case in our platform.
So it's great for mobile
applications, web applications.
If you have a lot
of JSON data, this
is a great place where you can
basically start from scratch
and scale up your application.
The other NoSQL application
that is our newest
is Cloud Bigtable.
It's currently in beta.
This is a wide-column store
that provides an HBase client
compatibility for you to build
your analytics applications.
This is really great for time
series data, metrics data,
things like advertising
technology, financial services,
and internet of things.
If you get a chance
tomorrow to attend
the talk by FIS about Bigtable,
I highly encourage it.
Really compelling
use case that they've
been able to use it for.
And the last one is cache.
So if you need an
in-memory key value store,
App Engine Memcache
is our solution
to allow you to put a
caching layer in front
of your application.
Commonly, this is
used in web, mobile,
and gaming applications.
Great.
So how do I get started?
So if you have an
idea and you want
to prototype it or build
something that you can share,
how would I do that?
So the simplest architecture
that you could put together
is a set of clients.
And this just might be
yourself or one or two friends.
And if you go down-- generally,
we see our developers split
into two different use cases.
Either they feel very
familiar with MySQL
and relational
databases, or they want
to develop NoSQL solutions.
So I'm going to talk
about both use cases
so that we can talk about
those as architectures.
We'll start with NoSQL.
So the simplest thing you can
do is spin up an App Engine
application and store
your application data
in Datastore and your static
data in Cloud Storage.
And so this should allow you,
with almost no configuration,
to get up and
running, storing data
that you can share
it back to a web
application or a
mobile application
just as a prototype.
Now, if you wanted to go down
the relational database path,
the way that you'd
do this is you
would spin up Compute Engine
to use whatever framework
you want.
Now, this could be
Node And we just
introduced Node in App Engine.
This could be Python Django
if you're a Python developer.
It could be WordPress
that you're running
on a Compute Engine instance.
And then you would,
again, set up a cloud SQL.
So you actually have
to think a little bit.
You have to set up an
instance, pick a size,
and tell us how much
storage you want.
And then you would
use Cloud Storage
just like you would
with the other solution
to store your static content.
So this can literally go from
zero to serving applications
in an hour.
This is the simplest
way that you
can get up and running on Google
Cloud and start serving data.
Now, if you take that
concept and you're like,
oh, this is interesting.
And I want to scale it out and
start to move it to production
and share it with more than
just me and a couple friends,
you have to start getting more
complicated architectures.
If you're going
down the MySQL path,
good news is App Engine
and Datastore will just
scale for you.
You don't have to
make any changes.
You just send it more
traffic, store more data,
and it'll scale for you.
Same thing for Cloud Storage.
These are fully
managed, leave it
and forget it type applications
that allow you to scale up.
So your architecture is very
similar for the NoSQL path.
If you're going down the
relational database path
and you need to
scale, and let's just
assume you have more
traffic than you
can put through a single VM, you
would put a Google Cloud load
balancer-- there's a couple
talks that would have happened
today about this-- in
front of several VMs
running WordPress, Django,
Node, Rails, whatever framework
you happen to be running.
And then speaking
back to Cloud SQL.
Now with Cloud SQL,
when you set it up,
if you are running in a
production environment,
you add a failover instance.
And that failover instance
gives you high availability.
So again, in a
fully managed way,
we'll give you a
multi-instance MySQL Cluster,
a set of replicas
that handle failover,
and if, for some reason
there's an issue with one
of with your primary
Cloud SQL instance,
we will failover to
the failover replica
so that you'll
have no down time.
This is all done with
a couple of clicks
when you set up
your MySQL instance.
Again, Cloud Storage for
all your static content.
Really the bedrock
of all of these
architectures for
your static content.
Great.
So now I've gotten up
to a gigabyte of data.
I've got a bunch of
data in my system.
And what am I get to do now?
So if you are continuing
to go down the RDBMS path,
if you've got MySQL
running, you now
have lots of websites
and lots of apps
all talking to your application.
So one thing, again, Cloud
Load Balancer-- and you
could do this with HAProxy or
whatever your favorite load
balancer is, but if you're
in the managed world where
you want Google to
manage it for you
and take advantage of our
amazing Site Reliability
Engineering
organization, then you
would use the
Cloud Load Balancer
to put in front of your VMs.
Again, to shard
your request traffic
to the various compute pieces.
And then go down to
the Cloud SQL level.
Now, Cloud SQL, it starts
to get more interesting.
Once you get above
the amount of traffic
that you can put
through a single VM,
then you have to start
thinking about how
to shard your traffic.
And this is where
MySQL starts-- you
have to take advantage of some
of the more advanced MySQL
features.
So in this case,
what you'd want to do
is have your Cloud SQL instance.
And you'd want to add
some read replicas.
So Cloud SQL offers
you the ability
to add as many read
replicas as you
want for your master instance.
And then at the
application layer,
you would want to shard your
write traffic and your read
traffic.
So all of your write traffic
would go to your master node.
So you could scale up to
the max number of requests,
max number of write
operations that you
can put through a single GC EVM,
which is what Cloud SQL Second
Generation uses under the hood.
And then add read replicas to
meet the amount of read traffic
that you have.
So this basically gives
you a certain level
of horizontal scalability to
split your write workloads
and your read workloads.
Again, all of this is
fully managed for you.
If something happens
to your read replica,
Google Site Reliability
Engineers will fix it.
If something happens to
your master instance,
then we will take your
failover instance,
set it up to be read-write,
and then move the IP address
over so that you'll have the
minimum amount of downtime.
You don't have to do anything.
This all happens for
you automatically.
It's all part of
the managed service
that Google offers for
Google Cloud Storage.
Some interesting things about
Cloud SQL Second Generation.
We released it in
December of last year.
It's currently in beta.
It is our fully
managed MySQL service.
It's 3 and 1/2 [INAUDIBLE]
of availability.
And one of the things we
just released that we're
very excited about is Hot Grow.
So what's great about this is
in the situation where you've
gone from a gigabyte
to a terabyte,
let's say that
you only specified
two gigabytes of storage
for your MySQL instance.
Now, if you were rolling
your own instance
and wanted to increase
the amount of disk,
you'd have to create
a new instance,
or shut down your
instance, create a snapshot
of your persistent disk volume.
Bring up a new PD volume
with that snapshot.
Re-attach it to the VM, and
then you could continue going.
But that, obviously,
requires a lot of work
and actually create
some downtime.
With How Grow on Cloud
SQL, you can literally
go from 10 gigabytes to 100
gigabytes to a terabyte,
all the way up to 10 terabytes,
with no downtime on the VM.
You can dynamically increase
the amount of capacity
that you need for Cloud SQL
and for you MySQL instance
without having any downtime.
So we're doing the
best that we can
to keep you from having to
make any decisions upfront,
and allowing you the flexibility
to increase your capacity
to meet whatever
load that you have.
So now, NoSQL.
So if you're going
down the NoSQL path,
again, the architecture
looks remarkably similar.
You've got a number of websites,
mobile applications speaking
to your App Engine app.
And then you're storing all
of your data in Datastore.
Now, some things you should
think about in Datastore.
Once you're starting to get
above a gigabyte of data,
and you're starting to get
to more meaningful amounts
of data, Datastore
offers you a number
of features that helps
with your performance
and allows you to tune.
So things like setting
up composite indexes,
and doing other
maintenance things
that you can do to
look at, do I need
indexes, what does
my traffic look like,
what is the performance
of my traffic,
what kind of
characteristics am I seeing?
And starting to use
some of the more
advanced features of Datastore
to tweak the application
to get better
performance out it.
Again, the beautiful
thing about Datastore
is, you don't have to choose
anything ahead of time.
You don't have to
say, I'm planning--
this application is
going to go viral
and I need a terabyte of data.
You just say, I need a
place to store some data.
You drop the data in.
And you just keep putting
data in that application.
And we will make
sure that we are
provisioned, very similar to
App Engine, to handle the load.
So there's no
pre-thought on Datastore.
It's a really
wonderful thing to be
able to just get started without
making any decisions ahead
of time.
And Datastore will work
with you to then scale up
your data to whatever the
size your application.
Cloud Datastore, fully
managed NoSQL service.
So it is, again-- I try
to position and talk
about it as a document
store type use case.
There's no schema.
You drop data in.
We do some inference
on the data to make
it easy to store and make it
as performant as possible.
But it is different
than Cloud SQL.
So Cloud SQL is a dedicated
resource system where you say,
this is my VM,
this is my compute.
And so you can do whatever
you want to that capacity.
With Datastore, it's
a multi-tenant system.
And so when you are
using the system,
we've put certain
limitations in place
to make sure that all of
your queries are fast.
So it's really designed to have
low latency, fast performance
all the time with,
again, no forethought.
You don't have to worry
about schema design.
about creating indexes.
We're going to do
as much of that
as we possibly can
automatically for you so
that the application will scale
once you put data into it.
All right.
Now we're starting to get a
little bit more interesting.
So now we're starting
into more than a terabyte.
So if you have more
than a terabyte of data,
you're generating some
interesting amounts of data.
And this is where a lot of
the talks that we've had today
lean to.
So when we talk about some
of the-- the Spotify use
case and some of
the other ones, it's
all about how are
they aggregating
lots and lots of data?
If you're talking about
Internet of Things,
and IoT, and the
sensor data, where
do you take all of that sensor
data, which is essentially
a timestamp and an
identifier and a value?
Where do you drop all that
data in a single place
with super-high read
throughput so that you can then
do table scans on it and get
some value out of it later?
So this is where
Cloud Bigtable is
what I'm really excited
about for this use case.
So three different
ways that you could
think about using
Cloud Bigtable.
So first of all, at
the device level.
And again, this could
be an IoT device.
It could be a device running
Brillo or Weave or whatever
you happen to be using.
And it's pushing telemetry
data back to the system.
Now, the way that it pushes
data back to the system
is it pushes the
data to Pub/Sub.
So every reading is a
single message on Pub/Sub.
And what's great
about Pub/Sub is
it's this globally
available message
queue that allows you to push
data to it from anywhere.
So that device
could literally be--
it doesn't have to be
anywhere near a data center.
It could be an individual
mobile device, or IoT device.
It pushes the data
back to Pub/Sub
for asynchronous processing.
Once that message gets
into Pub/Sub, it's durable.
It's not like running your own
message queue software on a VM.
It's globally available.
And again, Google Site
Reliability Engineers
are making sure that that's
always up and running.
The other thing
that's great about it,
and this is a recurring
theme, is that you
don't have to provision it.
You don't have to say,
I need 1,000 queries
per second of capacity.
You can just throw data at it.
And as long as
your data-- as long
as the number of requests
that you're sending
are lower than
millions of QPS, this
is something that we can handle
just because all of Google
runs on the same infrastructure.
So when you're sending
messages to Pub/Sub,
you're using the
same infrastructure
that Google uses for all of
our asynchronous processing.
And you can be confident
that the system's not
going to fall over.
If you need to push
us a petabyte of data,
you can have very
high confidence
that we are going to
be able to handle that,
because we have lots of
experiencing handling
that much data, both for
our internal applications
as well as our other
customer applications.
So once those messages
get into Pub/Sub,
how do you process them and
get them into Cloud Bigtable?
One example, and again,
there's many ways
to do this, is Dataflow.
So you can use Dataflow to
then pick up those messages,
do any transformations,
do any enriching, whatever
you want to do either in
a batch or a stream mode,
and push that data
into Cloud Bigtable.
So that's one way to do it.
You could do this
also with Dataproc.
If you have an Apache
Spark job that you
want to use for
streaming, if you
have a MapReduce job that you
want to use in your Hadoop
cluster, or that you've
been using on prem
that you want to use in
the cloud, both of those
provide you the ability to then
take that data from Pub/Sub
and drop it into Cloud Bigtable.
Other ways that you can do this.
So if you have a web device, or
if you have a web application
speaking to a VMware where
you're hosting application,
that VM can speak directly
to Cloud Bigtable.
So you can write directly
from x number of VMs
into Cloud Bigtable.
Another pattern that
we see very commonly
is microservice architecture.
So if you have a
number of mobile apps,
and those mobile apps
are all speaking back
to a microservice or
a RESTful endpoint,
you often need to collect
monitoring data from those.
This might be an event
user clicks a song
to play, in the Spotify use
case, or a user clicked a link,
or a user shut the
application or opened
the application, all of
that needs to be recorded.
So now, from the microservice,
you could push into Pub/Sub
and then data flow
into Bigtable,
or you could push
directly into Bigtable.
It all depends on
what your load is
and what your architecture
wants to look like.
What's great about
this is that once
you get the data
into Cloud Bigtable,
you have a lot of possibilities.
So Cloud Bigtable is our
fully managed, NoSQL,
wide-column service.
Cloud Bigtable, and
Bigtable internally,
and the Bigtable white paper,
spawned much of the Hadoop
ecosystem that we have today.
And so Cloud Bigtable
actually allows
you to use the original Cloud
Bigtable internal service
that much of Google
still runs on today.
We expose it via an HBase
client compatibility.
So we provide an
HBase client that you
can use to integrate with
your applications that
expect Hbase client.
But what's really interesting
about Cloud Bigtable,
and this is something we spend
a lot of time talking about is,
while we expose it as an
HBase client, it is not HBase.
And what's
interesting about that
is it's incredibly low latency,
random reads and writes.
And what this means is
that even though it's
meant to work in the
HBase analytic space,
latencies are such that you can
actually serve live application
data out of this.
So you can actually, with like
six millisecond latencies in
and out, you can serve
live application data out
of here, which is something that
most people wouldn't want to do
out of self-managed HBase.
Very interesting as
well, we're seeing
a lot of people that are
currently managing large HBase
and Cassandra clusters.
This is an interesting
option for them
if they want a managed service.
If you don't want
to roll your own
and manage your
own clusters, this
is a really interesting
option for people
to move those workloads
over and to have them
in a fully managed service
where Google SREs are
looking after your data.
The other thing that I'm
also very excited about
is a trend that we're
seeing externality,
that we've seen inside
Google for many years,
is this concept of HTAP,
which is Hybrid Transactional
Analytical Processing.
And the idea here is that
you can keep your application
data in the same place that
you do your analytics queries.
And it doesn't require you to
ETL the data into multiple data
centers doing transformations.
You can leave all the
data in a single place
and run your
applications from it,
as well as run your
analytics queries.
So obviously, this greatly
simplifies the architecture
of an application.
And what's great about
this is that this
is what we've been doing inside
of Google for many years.
Bigtable, BigQuery, things
that allow us to basically
have single solutions that
allow us to run our applications
as well as do our
analytics queries.
And Cloud Bigtable
is a perfect example
of how Google's internal
use case is starting
to manifest itself externally.
Two other things to look at.
Very excited-- a
partner, Pythian,
recently introduced OpenTSDB
support for Cloud Bigtable.
So if you are looking for a very
well adopted API for doing time
series data, OpenTSDB
on top of Cloud Bigtable
is a really interesting solution
All right.
So the talk is only supposed
to go up to petabytes,
but we're Google, so we
have to talk about exabytes.
So if you've gone
past petabytes of data
and you're approaching
towards an exabyte of data,
how would you go
about doing that?
So the first question is,
how would you actually get
that data into Google?
So we'll talk a little
bit about data ingestion
and how we're helping customers
get that data from either
on prem or other locations
onto Google Cloud Storage.
So the first one is
the Transfer Service.
So we offer Google
Cloud Transfer Service.
And this is a tool for helping
to move around your data.
So if you wanted to back
up all of your S3 data
into a GCS bucket, you could
do that, and set up a schedule
with Transfer Service.
If you want to move your data
from a GCS bucket, a Google
Cloud Storage bucket that's
currently in Standard,
and after 30 days
you want to move data
into a GCS bucket
which is Nearline,
then you can do that
using Transfer Service.
So we provide that
as a tool to help
people move that data around.
We're also trying to engage
really hard with our partner
ecosystem.
We really want to
enable our partners
and help our partners
help our customers get
this data into the system.
So the first one offline ingest.
So we worked with Iron Mountain
in the US for offline ingest,
and Prime Focus
abroad for helping
people do offline ingest.
So if you have
petabytes of data,
or even lots of
terabytes of data
that you want to get
moved in the system,
you can put them
into a hard drive
and you can ship those
to Iron Mountain.
And they will upload that
data into Google Cloud Storage
for you.
Same thing outside
the United States.
The other area that
we've really invested
in since we announced
Nearline last year
was the filer in the
on-premise file systems.
So in the middle
of last year, we
announced the
ability of Nearline.
So within Google
Cloud Storage, we now
have three different
storage classes.
The first one is
Standard, which is
what people have been using to
host their static web content.
And when they're using their
data processing pipelines.
Durable Reduced
Availability, which
in exchange for a slightly
lower SLA of availability,
you get a price break,
which is our second class.
And then the third
one we introduced
last year is Nearline.
And Nearline is our warm
storage archival solution
that allows you put your data
into a GCS bucket with Nearline
for basically archival.
And as part of that,
we've been working
with all of our
partners in the space
to help facilitate
that for customers.
A lot of these partners have
huge enterprise footprints
on premise, and they want
to be able to back up
their files to the cloud.
So how do we enable that and
make it easy for customers
to do that?
So working with the customers
like NetApp, Commvault, EMC,
Avere, making sure that
when you are running
those appliances on
prem, or some of them
in a Cloud Appliance, there
is the option for you to then
push that data into
Google Cloud Storage
so that you can back
it up, and again,
have Google's SREs
looking after your data
to make sure that it
is safe and secure
and always there
when you need it.
The last one that I
really like to talk about
is data pipelines.
And we've talked a little
bit about this earlier.
So great.
I've got 500 petabytes of
data in Google Cloud Storage.
Now what?
It's been sitting on prem.
I've never done
anything with it.
What is the value to me?
And most people just
want it as optionality
in case of a disaster.
They either need to keep it
from a compliance point of view,
or they just want to make sure
that if something happens,
they have a copy of their data.
What's so great about this
integrated data platform
approach is that once you get
your data into the system,
we can provide lots of
interesting tools for you
to be able to then take that
data and derive value from it
So first one we talked a little
bit about earlier is Dataflow.
So if you want to either
do batch or streaming--
and we've just recently
pushed this into Apache
as Apache Bean-- you
can use data flow
to run large factor stream
processes over your 500
petabytes of data to basically
clean it, extract value,
transform it, push
it into BigQuery,
do whatever you
need to do with it.
And again, fully
managed service.
If you need one petabyte of
data or 500 petabytes of data,
it's the same code.
It's running in the
same infrastructure,
the same set of APIs.
So we can scalably
go through your data
and help you derive value.
The second one is Dataproc.
And there's another talk just
after this one on Dataproc,
which I encourage
you guys to attend.
So Dataproc is really
helping customers
that are running
large on-prem Hadoop
installations to be
able to easily move
those workloads to the cloud.
So if you have a
MapReduce job that you've
been running on prem, once you
push all that data into Google
Cloud Storage, you want to be
able to run that MapReduce.
So Dataproc allows you to
just bring that MapReduce
into Google Cloud Platform,
and run that MapReduce
over your 500 petabytes of
data to get whatever value
or data extracted out
of that information.
And then in many of these, if
you're doing that processing
and trying to extract
value, you often
need a place to put that data.
So many times, people are
running these Dataflow jobs
and Dataproc jobs and
pushing data into BigQuery,
into a data warehouse,
where they can then
run their distribute queries.
Another thing that I'm very
excited about the direction
we're going, which
really speaks to the idea
that you can put
your data anywhere
and we'll help you drive
value is within BigQuery,
you can actually do
federated queries.
So you can do queries
against your data
that's already in BigQuery.
But you can also do
joins and queries
against your data in GCS.
So if you have your data in an
Avrom or Parquet file in GCS,
you can run BigQuery
queries against that data
and potentially join it with
data that you have in BigQuery.
But where this becomes really
interesting is that we can then
expand those federated
queries out to Cloud Bigtable
and Datastore and all
these other areas,
so that regardless of
where your data is,
you don't have to ETL it and
move it into another solution.
And you don't have to
ETL it into-- and by ETL,
is Extract,
Transform, and Load--
you don't have to
have a process to move
that data into BigQuery.
You can just do the
queries from BigQuery
and query your data in line.
So that's where it starts to
get really compelling where,
wherever your data is in the
Google Cloud data platform,
you'll be able to then
access that data and drive
value from it without having
to move it around and worry
about where it is.
One other thing, so in Dataproc,
so if you're using HBase,
we have HBase connectors.
So use that as an intermediate
point in Dataproc.
Also, connectors for Dataflow.
So making sure that all
of these various products
work really well
against Google Cloud
Storage to make it really easy
to move your files around.
And then no talk about
the Google Cloud platform
would be complete without
talking about our marketplace
solutions.
So in our marketplace
solutions, we're
working with a great
bunch of partners
so that if one of
these managed solutions
aren't the right
answer for you, then
we're working with our
partners to make sure
that there is something
available to you that
will hopefully meet your needs.
So I've highlighted some here.
We've been working with
MongoDB so that they're
available in the marketplace.
So if you need a MongoDB
cluster, you can do that.
EnterpriseDB for
if you Postgres.
Currently we don't offer
Postgres in Cloud SQL,
and so if you want to spin
up a Postgres cluster,
you can do so
through EnterpriseDB.
If you're looking to run
Cassandra, because maybe
your development team has a lot
of experience with Cassandra,
we offer a easy place
for you to take that data
and spin up a Cassandra,
either single node or cluster,
to be able to use that.
And same thing with Redis.
So if you need Redis
for your application,
we provide the ability for you
to spin up a Google Compute
Engine VM with Redis so
you can then immediately
start using it in
your application.
So just to finish up,
data is everything.
It's at the core of
everything we do.
We talk about a lot
of these applications,
and there's amazing things you
can do with machine learning.
And as you start to
build your own models,
you're going to need a place
actually store your data.
So where do you put
your training data?
It's going to be the
GCS bucket, or it's
going to be a Bigtable table.
And so there has to be a way to
get your data into the system
so you can start to do all these
amazing things with machine
learning and other things
that we're talking about.
And so what we're
doing is really
trying to make sure we have
that unified data platform
so that you can bring your data
into Google Cloud Platform,
you can put it in
the application that
makes sense for you so
that's cost effective,
it's the application or
framework or software
that you're accustomed
to working with.
And then once you do that,
we'll make it very easy
for you to be able to move it,
transform it, and derive value
from it.
And we want that to
all be in one place.
We don't want this
to be something
that you have to think about.
As I talked about
before, we're always
trying to give you optionality.
We want you to be able to
choose the solution that you
think is best for you.
And then as you scale up,
make it as easy as possible
to scale up your
application to meet
the needs of your
users and your business
without having to make a
bunch of decisions up front.
We don't want you
to have to provision
what you're doing in the future.
We don't want you
to have foresight
into what your company
or business or use case
is going to look like.
We want to make it
easy for you get up
and running as
quickly as possible,
and allow you to scale so your
business can be successful.
That's it.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]